in this building behind here I'm looking
forward to seeing the accelerators where
they actually made the elements by the
time we get to here the ions already
traveling at five percent of the speed
of life
I will show you the biggest secret so
it's really a real first for me I've
never met anybody who's discovered an
element are usually this hidden in the
vacuum box and you don't see it I just
opened it to show it to you I'm in the
coffee room where element 109 meitnerium
was named in here imagine it 20 people
sitting around arguing what we can pull
this new element
six new elements have been born in this
this is the maternity ward where they've
all been born